Cobra Kai has captured the nostalgia of a
multi-generational franchise.
But the characters aren't the only things
viewers find familiar.
Samantha's actress, Mary Mouser, has been
working for years.
Here's where you might have seen her before.
Prior to her role as Sam LaRusso on Cobra
Kai, actress Mary Mouser played a recurring
role on Hulu's high-school horror series Freakish.
In that show, a bunch of kids show up for
detention but find themselves fighting off
killer zombies after a nearby chemical plant
explodes.
It's like the John Hughes classic, The Breakfast
Club, except the kids in detention aren't
just in trouble -- they're on the menu.
Mouser plays Mary Jones, little sister to
Grover, another one of the lead characters.
Those who survive the initial attack must
figure out how to make it out alive without
much in the way of supplies or protection.
Mouser only had the role of Mary for one of
the show's two seasons, which is a pretty
good run considering the body count of a zombie
show.
Mary Mouser played the role of Lacey Fleming
on the medical-crime-meets-comedy-drama series
Body of Proof prior to tying her gig as Sam
LaRusso.
Before she was Daniel-san's daughter, she
was the nearly estranged daughter of medical
examiner Megan Hunt, a former neurosurgeon
no longer able to operate after suffering
nerve damage in a car crash.
Mouser's character was considered a recurring
role for the show's first season, at which
time Lacey lived with her father.
Mouser was promoted to the main cast for the
second and third seasons, as Megan gains joint
custody with her ex-husband, and her relationship
with her daughter slowly evolves, while Lacey
is shuttled back and forth between parents.
Body of Proof was canceled by ABC in 2013
after three seasons.
There are characters on a TV show who shape
the world of the series with their presence,
and then there are characters who rarely appear,
but whose spirit hangs over everything.
Mouser got the opportunity to play one such
character on CBS' long running crime drama
NCIS.
As the deceased daughter, Kelly, of Special
Agent Gibbs, Mouser may have only appeared
in a few of the series' 400+ episodes, but
she's still arguably one of the more important
figures of the whole show.
At the beginning of NCIS' run, fans were left
to guess as to why Gibbs has such a tough
exterior and often secretive personality.
That changed in season 3, when the show revealed
that he once had a wife and daughter who were
killed by a member of a drug cartel.
Gibbs later killed the man in revenge, and
the entire dark episode and the memories of
his past continue to haunt him throughout
his life.
Mouser played Kelly in several flashback sequences
throughout the series, most notably in the
episodes "Hiatus Parts I & II."
While you might not recognize the significantly
younger Mouser right away, NCIS fans may have
sensed Kelly's presence while watching Cobra
Kai.
Typically, when you see that somebody had
a one-episode guest starring role on Criminal
Minds it's either because they played a terrifying
killer, or a terrified victim.
While the series is known for its exceptionally
grisly cases, Mouser's character from the
season 10 episode "Amelia Porter" survived
with some deep emotional scars, but relatively
minor physical ones.
Rebecca is a teenager who becomes one of the
targets of her uncle, Benton Farland, who
has recently been released from prison after
serving time for the murder of Rebecca's mother.
While Benton didn't kill Rebecca's mother
himself, he manipulated his girlfriend at
the time, the titular Amelia Porter, to do
so.
Now that he's a free man, he desperately wants
to not only reunite with Amelia, but also
have her recreate the murder he coerced her
into committing.
Unfortunately for Rebecca, she looks just
like her mother, so Benton kidnaps her in
preparation for his twisted reunion.
"You don't recognize her?
It's Rebecca, Miriam's daughter.
Doesn't she look just like her mother?"
Thankfully, Amelia isn't as interested in
playing along this time.
She stalls long enough for the Behavioral
Analysis Unit squad to show up and rescue
Rebecca, putting Mouser in the special category
of Criminal Minds guest stars whose characters
didn't die a horrific death.
Freeform's groundbreaking show The Fosters
centers on Stef and Lena Adams Foster, a married
couple with a large family composed of their
biological, adopted, and foster children.
Unsurprisingly, the series featured a sizable
cast of characters throughout its five season
run, including Sarah Lewis, played by Mouser.
Sarah only has a three episode-arc on the
show, but they make up a pretty memorable
three episodes.
Mouser plays a fellow foster kid who meets
Callie, one of Stef and Lena's charges, in
a therapy group.
Unfortunately for Sarah, she is being groomed
by one of Callie's former foster brothers,
Liam, who Callie knows to be manipulative
and regularly involved with girls who are
far too young for him to be dating.
After getting wrapped up in Liam's criminal
activity, it looks like Sarah may be at risk
of getting dragged down with Liam, but with
the help of Callie, she's eventually able
to break the spell and turn against him.
Prank calls are all fun and games until the
playful charade starts to take on a life of
its own and morph into something unsettling.
In "Prank Call," the season 3 episode of the
HBO anthology series Room 104, Mouser stars
as a teenager who stumbles into that lesson
in the worst possible way.
Each episode of Room 104 focuses on a new
temporary inhabitant of the hotel room that
gives the series its name.
In "Prank Call," that person is Adrienne,
whose parents have left her alone for the
night.
To pass the time, Adrienne makes prank calls.
Far from lighthearted jokes, Adrienne's calls
see her adopting personas that are more grown-up
than she's ready for.
When she connects with a man named George,
she lets her flirtatious older woman persona
get away from her.
Before she can put an end to the disturbing
situation, a knock on the hotel room door
escalates the prank to a terrifying degree.
"Prank Call" is a twisted and often disturbing
episode of TV, but it provides Mouser with
a multi-layered part to sink her teeth into.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.